In the previous part of the video,
we saw that 1 mole of something is nothing but
6.022 times 10 raised to 23 particles.
It could be atoms or molecules or anything.
If I give you one mole of pure gold,
then what will the number of atoms in it be equal to?
Yes, these many atoms.
And 1 mole of pure water
will have these many molecules.
But what is the scientific definition of a Mole?
Scientifically, 1 mole is defined as
the amount of substance that contains
the same number of atoms, molecules or particles
as there are atoms in 12 grams of Carbon-12.
Yes, even I didn't understand it when we read it for the first time.
Let me break it down for you.
Let me remove this definition from the screen.
What we have on the screen now is
12 grams of carbon-12.
Carbon-12 is one of the isotopes of carbon.
Now 12 grams of carbon-12
is what was taken as a standard.
What’s so special about this?
Can you guess the number of atoms here?
Yes, its 'Six point zero two two’ times
‘ten raised to twenty three’ atoms.
Now that you’ve understood this,
let me repeat the definition for you.
One mole is defined as the amount of substance
that contains the same number of atoms,
molecules or particles
as there are atoms in 12 grams of carbon-12.
Did you understand the definition now?
It consists of two simple parts actually.
It tells us that this part is equal to this part.
The number of particles in one mole of a substance
is equal to the number of atoms in 12 grams of carbon-12.
That’s it. That’s all the definition tells us.
Many people get confused when it comes to the concept of mole.
Let’s take many more examples to be absolutely sure.
How about taking the same example of pure gold
and pure water?
When we say one mole of pure gold
then according to our definition,
it will have the same NUMBER OF ATOMS
as the number of atoms in 12 grams of Carbon-12.
That means one mole of gold
will have 'six point zero two two times'
'ten raised to twenty three' atoms of gold.
Similarly, water will also have the same NUMBER OF MOLECULES
as the number of atoms in 12 grams of carbon-12.
That means it will have "six point zero two two" times
"ten raised to twenty three" molecules of water.
Remember, the definition uses carbon-12 as a standard.
It is used to compare the NUMBER of atoms
or molecules or particles present in the substance.
But what’s the mystery behind this number?
A scientist named Lorenzo Romano Amedeo Carlo Avogadro,
came up with this concept.
I know the name is long.
So we will address him as Avogadro.
So the number "six point zero two two" times
"ten raised to twenty three"
is called as the Avogadro’s number.
It is just a number used to represent quantities.
Its similar to how we use the word ‘pair’ for 2,
or the word ‘dozen’ to represent 12.
Similarly, Avogadro’s number is the term
used to represent "six point zero two two" times
"ten raised to twenty three" number of any entity.
So can we go to a shop and say
“I want Avogadro’s number of chocolates?"
Of course we can.
The only problem is
that the shop won’t really have those many chocolates
and neither will we be able to carry them back home.
So getting back to the concept,
Avogadro’s number is just another number
used to represent quantities.
But the number is so huge that using this in daily life
is not practically possible and advisable.
Then why does the number exist if we do not use it?
Yes the number is not commonly used in daily life by us.
However, it comes to the rescue of chemists
that work with atoms, molecules, electrons
and many such small entities.
That is the reason why it is used to calculate one mole
of any substance.
Let’s talk about one last concept.
We know that one mole of carbon-12 is 12 grams of carbon-12.
That’s because 12 grams of carbon-12
has the Avogadro’s number of atoms.
Now let me ask you a question.
If you answer this correctly,
it means you’ve understood the concept of mole.
What will be the mass of one mole of pure gold?
Will it be 12 grams?
The answer is no. It will not be 12 grams.
Note that in both cases, the number of atoms is the same.
But the mass of an atom of gold
is different from the mass of an atom of ‘carbon 12’.
Hence the mass of 1 mole of gold will definitely be
different from the mass of one mole of carbon-12.
So one mole of gold weighs around 196.97 grams.
That is because mass of gold atom
is different from the mass of Carbon-12 atoms.
Similarly, one mole of water
will have the Avogadro’s number of molecules,
but it will not weigh 12 grams.
So if we take one mole of water and find its mass,
we get the answer as 18.015 grams of water.
And I’m sure you know why.
For the sake of comparison,
if we take one mole of gold, one mole of silver
and one mole of copper,
then all of them will have the same number of
atoms in them.
That is ‘six point zero two two’ times
‘ten raised to twenty three’ atoms.
This number is the Avogadro’s number.
However, the mass of each one will be different.
That's because the mass of individual atoms
that make up these elements is different.